you do very you do clean comedy it's for
families and the and in an era when
maybe that wouldn't be so popular but
I've noticed as a sketch for a former
sketch writer myself the the sketches
are very well constructed you guys do a
really nice job there well put together
and it's good comedy and I like that my
kids like it because the sketches have a
beginning middle and end and they're
often very clever how do you guys do it
oh well I mean the way we keep it clean
is well I mean we have a staunch Irish
Catholic grandmother in the writers room
at all time I have one of those in my
mind all the time but she's not able to
stop me we really wanted to fill a niche
that wasn't being occupied anymore I
mean not as many people are doing family
entertainment and I goal - we don't our
goal wasn't to like make like children's
programming we just wanted to make funny
content that everyone could watch yeah
you know so you don't to worry about
watching with your kids or your staunch
Catholic grandmother right like anyone
exactly what's nice is though I've
noticed that all the all of my my
daughter is 13 my son's 11 all of their
friends talk about studio C and they all
know the sketches by heart who's
approaching you on the street I mean
when my kids saw you
they started screech I didn't know what
had happened I thought there I literally
thought there was a rat in the
restaurant they jumped up and they don't
react this way to anybody and they
started screaming and they said Studio C
Studio C and they ran towards you guys
is that what happens to you when young
people see you it does sometimes yeah
and in the strangest of places you know
people really feel like they know us we
use our real names on the show and so
they come up and they call us by name
and they'll they'll give us hugs and
stuff like that I got hugged in a
haunted house once that was frightening
that's weird someone come up to you at a
haunted house and hug you that's not a
good time to express admiration for your
work yeah we did some weird stuff I had
a guy one time who thought another black
dude was me my friend told me the story
cuz she witness sitting he just screamed
Stacey for like three minutes as this
guy walked across the campus he was like
Stacey
he was like crying by the end Sydnor
them that's it's nice break the news you
know he's probably watching this now and
like holy crap
my brother in Boston looks a lot like me
were just one year apart and he's had
people follow him for blocks and then he
just goes I'm his brother and they're
there to like say mean things so you've
got this you've got you do and do you
find that older people approach you to
do you ever find that there's like
adults that are watching the show as
well well we had one of our cast members
Jason he was he was in the hospital with
his wife she was in labor and the nurse
is like so could I get a picture in
labor in labor
yeah and Jason was so caught off guard I
think he said yes yeah
and Jenny his wife is like no yeah and
then the newborn baby photobombs
you